So my name's Rif-- CEO
and founder of Foodit.
And Google asked
me to talk today
a bit about how we're
using their Cloud Platform.
And I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about our journey,
about getting to where we are
today, and about platforms,
and what we're all about.
And I read a book,
"Lean Startup,"
and it talked a lot
about MVPs all the time.
And when I actually look back
over the last 12 months-- yes,
we're going out there
trying to test our products,
but also test the people and
the platform at the same time.
So, just my background.
I was a CEO and a developer for
12 years-- a food distribution
company that sells
food to 45,000
restaurants across the UK.
So I'm a bit technical.
I had experiences doing
stuff, building stuff.
I had a great team.
But it got to a
point in my career
where I just wanted
to do something else
and JJs wanted to support
me in that process.
So I had already
funding, which is great.
But I wanted to build something.
And day one I had no team.
I had no idea what
I wanted to build.
I just finished reading "Lean
Startup" and I was ready to go,
I was ready to start testing.
And I didn't want to do things
the way I used to do them.
I didn't want to deal with
servers, and patching,
and networks, and
all the other stuff.
So I was trying to
figure out that, hey I've
got all this money now how am
I going to get the product out
of the door as fast as
possible and start testing it
real restaurants.
So I went out to
market and thought
about if I could come up
with what my MVP looked
like-- or my product
looked like-- maybe I
could go and work with a
couple different companies.
And I thought, well because
I've got all this money let
me try and do this
all at the same time.
And one of the other things
I did at the same time
was I used 99designs.com
to start picking logos.
We got like 2,500 entries.
It's once of the
nice, fun things
to do when you're
starting a startup.
So that's me, I guess,
standing on the US.
And we have three
development teams
in different parts
of the world building
the same minimal,
viable product.
And we picked-- I picked
three different platforms
to do that on, to test out
three different things.
The first thing while doing
this I knew after reading "Lean
Startup" is I wasn't testing how
to build a restaurant website.
So Foodit was to do a whole
bunch of things of restaurants.
But the main thing I
wasn't trying to do
was learn how to build
a restaurant website.
What I was trying
to learn how to do
was get a restaurant website
to be found on Google as
quickly as possible,
learn if restaurants
are willing to pay
for the service,
and also understand if people
would trust a restaurant
website as a place
to order food.
And those are the three
things I was trying to test.
So how I was going
to build the website,
all those things I didn't think
was going to affect my startup.
So I thought, what's the
risk of doing this three
times with three
different companies?
So I found the company
to build themselves
up a product called Magento.
Magento is an
e-commerce platform.
And I thought the
reason I'd want
to do that would
be if I could get
to use the power of Magento I
could get stuff like billing,
pricing, vouchers--
and all the stuff
that a normal e-commerce
platform would have--
into my product as
quickly as possible.
And the thing I
was trying to test
by building on top
of Magento was,
would I get into
issues or constraints
that-- hey, I've got 200,000
restaurants across the world.
Would Magento scale?
Would I have to do really
horrible things to the product
to make it work the way
I wanted it to work?
Because Magento is typically
designed for an e-commerce site
that has just one store--
or just one web page--
not 200,000 web pages.
So I found the company and
we went on this journey
to try and build up.
At the same time, I'm
a big fan of Microsoft
and I wanted to see if I could
find a low-cost team in India--
or anywhere else-- that
could build on top of Azure,
like some Azure platform,
to build this same product.
And I was always a big fan of
Google App Engine since 2008,
even though my previous
job was all Microsoft.
And I wanted to see if we could
use Google App Engine, which--
just as the talk showed
before-- gives you
a lot of the tools
out of the box,
preconfigured, preset,
to build what you want.
And I found a team
in Australia--
who were also very much into
"Lean Startup"-- to do that.
The cool thing about
the Australian team
is they're called Three Weeks.
And the reason they're
called Three Weeks
is that they will get your
MVP built in three weeks time.
So that set the actual pace
for the other three teams
around the world to
build the product.
And the good thing was it
made me focus on those things
that I wanted to learn.
Would restaurants pay for it?
Would this happen,
would that happen?
And not focus on which
database I'm going to pick
and which Memcache served
them, which RESTful API,
and how are we going to
lay out the load balancers.
In my previous role
as a CIO I found
that we would waste
huge amounts of time
debating pros, and cons, and ifs
for the future 12, 24 months.
And when you're in an
enterprise environment
you have that luxury.
And when you're in a
position where you already
have like 200 million
pounds worth of orders
going through a
platform then you
have to debate
stuff to make sure
that you don't just
break it the next day.
But I didn't want to get
back into that world.
So I really want to something
like Google App Engine, which
says this is the database
you're going to use,
this is how you're
going to build stuff.
You have a certain amount
of choice and flexibility
but you're going to remove
that away from the developer.
Otherwise you could
spend a little time
fighting and arguing about
what is the best choice.
But the reality is
that's probably not
going to make you win or
lose the startup you're
trying to build.
You have a bunch of
things you need to learn,
and unless your
startup is actually
building a platform
for developers
you probably want
to focus on, what
is the thing I need to
learn and which platform
is going to get me there
as quickly as possible.
So I went out there
and tried those three
different platforms.
Magento, it was just
too much for me.
I had to break it too much to
make it work for my startup.
And I felt like within
a couple of months
I would be rewriting
everything again.
So it didn't work.
But it would have given
us a lot of features
as quickly as possible-- good
lot of features as quickly
as possible.
But 12 months past that now
I've still not used any of those
features in my startup.
So they would have
been redundant.
And everything that I've
needed has been stuff
that we had to build
in a custom way.
The Azure team-- Azure
as a platform was great.
But the team itself,
they were just too much--
too developer-focused.
They needed to take too
much of my time and too much
specifications.
And the team in Australia,
those developers
are willing to go out to see
restaurants and get feedback,
and I needed to spend
little time with them.
And the thing I liked
about App Engine
was that there was a
preset way of doing things.
So that as I moved that team
from using an external company
in-house-- those
developers-- there's
a set way of using
Google BigQuery,
there's a set way of
using Google Datastore,
and there's a set pattern.
So this team in Australia
is not deciding,
oh were going to have 20 servers
doing this and 10 servers
doing that.
They just write the code.
And Google App Engine deals
with how many boxes are needed
and the pattern.
of doing it.
So in summary, food is yummy.
I would argue that if you
look at Myspace and Facebook--
one was written in Coldfusion,
one was written in PHP.
Did it matter to the success or
the failures of either company?
I would always, always
say, look at your start up.
What are you trying to build?
What are you trying to learn?
And how much
technology is a factor
for if you're going
to win or lose?
So today we're talking
about some web platforms.
But part of our
technology is running
a printer in the
kitchen of restaurants.
And we picked Android to do that
because Android-- unlike iOS--
allows you to control the
USB port of the device.
So I can plug a printer in
without using Bluetooth.
So I could not do that on iOS.
So look at the thing
you're trying to build.
I would say if you want
to build something that's
very heavy orientated
to Facebook,
or if you want to
build something
for people that use
Microsoft Office,
there might be other
platforms out there
that have features that might
work better for your startup.
Do you need low-level access
to your operating system?
If you're not
developers yourselves,
you're going to
have a hard time--
or an enjoyable time--
trying to figure out
is what your developer
saying actually important.
Like they're saying, oh
we should use MongoDB,
or we should use this
or we should that,
and it's going to make it
great because xx,y, and zed.
But is that what
you're trying to learn?
So try and stay focused on
what's important to be learned.
And if your developer
feels comfortable
building fast on this platform
then maybe go down that route.
Trying to get them to switch
something and learn something
new might take more time.
Do you trust what
you're building on?
There's hundreds and
hundreds of platforms
to build out there on.
If one of them just goes
bankrupt tomorrow than you
might have a hard time.
So I trust the Google App Engine
is going to be there tomorrow.
I trust that Google is going
to keep developing on it,
and building it, and
making it better--
which they have
proven to have done.
And just stay focused on
what you're trying to learn.
And make sure that the
platform you picked
is aligned with those things.
I'm going to be around here
for the rest of the day.
I'm also a Google Developer
Expert for Cloud,--
like Steve-- for Maps.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]